REPUBLICANS, IF, IN FACT, THEY
HAVE ANY HOPE OF TAKING OVER THE
SENATE.
IN FACT, IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE G.O.P.
REGAINS MAJORITIES IN BOTH THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE IN THE FALL
AFTER TWO YEARS OF TOTAL
DEMOCRATIC CONTROL, THIS COUNTRY
IS FALLING APART, DANGEROUSLY
SO.
LOOK AT THE STOCK MARKET TODAY.
IT TANK YET AGAIN.
INFLATION AT A 42 YEAR HIGH,
INTEREST RATES NOW GOING UP
THROUGH THE ROOF.
THIS IS REALLY CRUSHING EVERYONE
IN THIS COUNTRY, ESPECIALLY THE
POOR, THE MIDDLE CLASS.
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS ON FIXED
INCOMES.
AND NOW TOP ECONOMISTS ARE
CALLING STAGFLATION
"UNAVOIDABLE."
THE CEO OF WELLS FARGO SAYING
THERE IS NO QUESTION, BAD DAYS
ARE AHEAD.
ANALYSTS, MORGAN STANLEY, SMART
PEOPLE, THEY ARE BLAMING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
INFLATION.
INDIAN FAR LEFT FOX IS BLASTING
JOE'S OUT-OF-CONTROL SPENDING.
AND IT GETS EVEN WORSE, TODAY,
ONCE AGAIN, GAS PRICES SHOOTING
TO THE MOON, AND TODAY, ANOTHER
BRAND-NEW RECORD HIGH PRICE FOR
A GALLON OF GASOLINE.
IN FACT, EVERY DAY FOR THE PAST
NINE DAYS, GAS PRICES SET ONE
NEW RECORD AFTER ANOTHER.
NOW THIS YEAR, AMERICAN FAMILIES
WILL HAVE TO FORK OVER ANYWHERE
BETWEEN $5,200 TO $5,700 AND
GOING HIGHER THANKS TO
JOE BIDEN'S INFLATION.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU DRIVE A CAR,
YOU ARE GOING TO PAY $2,000 MORE
ON AVERAGE JUST FOR GASOLINE
THIS YEAR OVER WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT.
AND OF COURSE, THE
ADMINISTRATION LIKES TO BLAME
ALL OF OUR PROBLEMS ON
CORPORATIONS AND VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND SOMETHING THEY ARE CALLING
ULTRA MAGA, OH, YOU MEAN WHEN
GAS PRICES WERE CHEAP, THE
BORDER WAS UNDER CONTROL,
OPERATION WARP SPEED ACTUALLY
WORKED AND WE DID NOT RUN OUT OF
TESTS AFTER TWO YEARS?
AND EVERY OTHER DISASTER, FROM
AFGHANISTAN TO THE WAR IN
EUROPE.
THIS WEEK, BIDEN'S NEW PRESS
SECRETARY DID NOT SEEM TO KNOW
WHO TO BLAME OR WHAT TO SAY.
IT WAS NOT A GOOD START TAKE A
LOOK.
>> HOW DOES RAISING TAXES ON
CORPORATIONS LOWER THE COST OF
GAS, THE COST OF A USED CAR, THE
COST OF FOOD FOR EVERY DAY
AMERICANS?
>> SO, LOOK, I THINK WE
ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO HAVE DONE
VERY WELL, RIGHT, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO CARE ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE, TO SUPPORT A FAIRER TAX
CODE THAT DOES NOT CHANGE --
THAT DOES NOT CHARGE
MANUFACTURERS, WORKERS, COPS,
BUILDERS, A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
THEIR EARNINGS, THAT THE MOST
FORTUNATE PEOPLE IN OUR NATION,
AND NOT LET THAT STAND IN THE
WAY OF REDUCING ENERGY COSTS AND
FIGHTING THIS EXISTENTIAL
PROBLEM, IF YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
AS AN EXAMPLE.
AND TO SUPPORT BASIC COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS, AS WELL,
RIGHT, THAT IS ALSO IMPORTANT.
LOOK, IT IS -- WITHOUT HAVING A
FAIRER TAX CODE, WHICH IS WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT, THEN LIKE
MANUFACTURING WORKERS, COPS, IT
IS NOT FAIR FOR THEM TO HAVE TO
PAY HIGHER TAXES THAN THE FOLKS
WHO ARE NOT PAYING TAXES AT ALL.
>> Sean: FORGET THAT WORD
SALAD YOU JUST HEARD, TAKE A
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
LOOK AT QUINNIPIAC.
2%, THAT IS RIGHT, 2% OF
AMERICANS NOW BELIEVE OUR
ECONOMY IS IN EXCELLENT SHAPE,
AND THEY KNOW JUST WHO TO BLAME,
A WHOPPING 63% BLAME JOE BIDEN.
OUR ULTRA FAILURE OF A
PRESIDENT.
WANT TO TALK ABOUT ULTRA?
HE IS AN ULTRA FAILURE.
HIS APPROVAL RATING, LOOK AT
THAT, IS AT 32%.
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF,
AS AMERICANS HAVE SUFFERED FROM
A SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS, NOW A
BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE, SPIKING
INFLATION, SPIKING GAS PRICES, A
STOCK MARKET IN FREE FALL, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, OH, THEY
WERE BUSY TACKLING THE REAL
CRISIS: DISINFORMATION.
IN FACT, THEY SPENT A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME AND
ENERGY AND EFFORTS TO DEVELOP A
BRAND-NEW MINISTRY OF TRUTH THAT
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT TO
POLICE ALL OF YOUR THOUGHTS.
WE DO HAVE GREAT NEWS TONIGHT.
THE MINISTRY OF TRUTH OR
DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE BOARD,
AS IT WAS COINED, IS NOW ON
PAUSE.
THAT FAR LEFT LUNATIC TAPPED TO
LEAD THE SHADY NEW VENTURE HAS
NOW RESIGNED, AND AS IT TURNS
OUT, FORMER DISINFORMATION CZAR,
NINA JANKOWICZ, WAS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PERPETRATORS AND
PURVEYORS OF DISINFORMATION IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
NOW SHE PRAISED RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION DOSSIER AUTHOR
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, SHE ACCUSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF BEING A
RUSSIAN PLANT, SHE REFERRED TO
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP SCANDAL
AS A DEBUNKED TRUMP CAMPAIGN
PRODUCT, AND LIKE MANY OTHER
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS, NINA
JANKOWICZ IS A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST WHO WANTS ALL AMERICANS
TO BELIEVE HER TWISTED OPINIONS
AND LIES ARE FACTS.
NOW TODAY, WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE
DISINFORMATION CZAR'S
RESIGNATION, WELL, BIDEN'S PRESS
SECRETARY WAS ONCE AGAIN SHORT
ON ANSWERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO IF IT IS PAUSING BECAUSE
YOU THINK THE BOARD WAS
MISCHARACTERIZED, THEN THE
DISINFORMATION BOARD IS BEING
SHUT DOWN BECAUSE OF
DISINFORMATION?
IS THAT WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE?
>> LOOK, THE BOARD WAS PUT
FORWARD FOR A PURPOSE, RIGHT, TO
MAKE SURE WE REALLY DID ADDRESS
WHAT WAS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHEN IT CAME TO
DISINFORMATION.
>> 75 DAYS --
>> IT IS GOING TO PAUSE.
THERE HAS BEEN A
MISCHARACTERIZATION FROM
OUTSIDE -- OUTSIDE FORCES, AND
SO WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO IS WE
ARE GOING TO PAUSE IT AND WE ARE
GOING TO DO AN ASSESSMENT.
BUT THE WORK DOESN'T STOP.
WE ARE STILL GOING TO CONTINUE
THE WORK.
>> Sean: THEY ARE GOING TO
WORK.
SO IT IS ALIVE OR IS IT GONE?
ANYWAY, DOES ANYONE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAVE A STRAIGHT
ANSWER FOR ANYTHING?
DO THEY TAKE ANY RESPONSIBILITY,
HAVE THEY EVER HEARD OF THE
PHRASE THE BUCK STOPS HERE?
KEEP IN MIND, EVEN ON LUCID
DAYS, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS TOTALLY
INCOMPETENT, HIS DHS
SECRETARY CARES MORE ABOUT
POLICING YOUR THOUGHTS THEN
SECURING OUR BORDER.
HIS TREASURY SECRETARY IS A
LUNATIC WHO TOLD US INFLATION
WAS TRANSITORY.
HIS VICE PRESIDENT, TOTALLY IN
OVER HER HEAD, INEPT, AND SHE
NEVER REALLY SEEMS TO KNOW WHAT
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THAT IS ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS,
WHICH IS WHY WE WILL WORK
TOGETHER AND CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES, TO TACKLE THESE
CHALLENGES, AND TO WORK TOGETHER
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK,
OPERATING FROM THE NEW NORMS,
RULES, AND AGREEMENTS, THAT WE
WILL CONVENE TO WORK TOGETHER
ON.
>> Sean: WE WILL ALL WORK
TOGETHER.
THAT IS THE PLAN.